there are things that can be done in the
world things that should be done in the
world that only you can do and that if
you don't do them they won't happen
that's a high Vision that's a high
calling by the way that's true of our
country our country will be less if you
don't take on the obligations of
citizenship this country can be greater
it can be more with you as part of it
and it won't be what it could be without
you we need you yeah well I and I think
that's true is that to the degree that
each person is unique and their each
person is unique to a great degree then
each person has something to bring into
the world that only they could bring
into it that's a heavy load for each
person to bear too because it turns out
that it isn't true that nothing you do
matters what's true is that everything
you do matters a lot more than you think
and you should get the hell out of it
now when people do abdicate their
responsibility on Moss which is what you
saw in well Nazi Germany what you saw in
totalitarian Soviet Union and in Mao's
China that things turn into hell very
very rapidly
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and thanks for tuning in
to everyone who's watching and listening
I have the privilege today of speaking
with senator
Joshua Hawley
Republican Joshua Hawley is a lawyer who
has served as the junior United States
senator from Missouri since 2019.
from 2017 to 2019 Senator Hawley was the
42nd Attorney General of Missouri he
graduated from Stanford in 2002
completed a postgraduate internship at
St Paul's School in London from 2002 to
2003 and then attended law school at
Yale graduating in 06. he was a law
clerk to 10th Circuit Judge Michael W
McConnell and Chief Justice John Roberts
from o 6 208 and worked as a lawyer in
private practice from 08 to 11.
Senator Hawley also served as an
associate professor at the University of
Missouri school of law where he taught
constitutional law
and he served as a faculty member of the
conservative Blackstone legal Fellowship
he's known as a powerful and upcoming
voice on the social conservative front
welcome Senator Hawley thanks very much
for agreeing to speak with me today
thanks for having me yeah my pleasure my
pleasure I think we might as well dive
right into the political role that we're
going to get into the philosophical and
perhaps the theological arguably as the
conversation progresses and so we're
recording this mid-october the midterms
are coming up in the U.S this is a
crucial election in many ways what do
you see happening on the midterm front
well I think that the Republicans are
going to retake the house I think we're
going to retake the Senate as well we're
at a 50 50 balance right now in the
United States Senate it's actually
Jordan the longest 50 50 split in the
United States Senate in history and
American history I think that's going to
come to an end here in a few weeks I
predict Republicans will take back
majorities in in both houses and then in
many ways the really difficult work for
republicans and conservatives is going
to begin which is a to stop this deeply
unpopular and I would argue deeply
destructive agenda of the radical left
which has taken over the Biden
Administration but then also we're going
to have to start to put forward an
alternative agenda and that's something
I think conservatives need to give a lot
of thought to I'm not sure that we've
given it enough thought as a as a party
as a group and it's going to be very
pressing I think
yeah well the the conservatives are
always pilloried by the left as
reactionary and I think the reason for
that is well first of all the the right
the conservatives do react to the
excesses of the left constantly as the
left nibbles away like piranhas at the
entire structure of of the society but I
think conservatives are often set back
on their heels on the vision front too
because it's not that easy to articulate
a defense of let's say axiomatic
presumptions you know I've I've often
thought if you approach someone who's
conservative and you say something like
justify marriage
it's it's easy to render the person so
assaulted let's say inarticulate because
while we've basically agreed that
marriage is a good thing for some tens
of thousands of years and it's not that
easy to formulate uh Visionary defense
of Institutions that in some sense you
might think that everybody takes for
granted in terms of their value
and so I see this on the conservative
front it's not easy at all on I've
talked to conservatives all over Europe
and Canada and the US it's not easy at
all for them to formulate a vision that
particularly one that's attractive to
young people so what do you think
beckons on the on that front for
conservatives
well I think that that what we're seeing
right now what's at play in this
election really is the the sort of
fundamental foundations of American
culture Jordan I think what's driving
American politics is is culture and its
society and if you look at what the left
is doing in our country in the United
States the left is attacking the
foundations of American culture and the
foundations of American society it's
really a campaign of of political
nihilism and what they're saying is is
that America is systemically unjust
systemically oppressive systemically
evil and their their whole effort is and
by the way so is our our free market
system it's systemically uh warped and
so their entire campaign really and
their message to the American people and
to young people is that we need to
bulldoze it and start all over and and
they want to reconstruct our society and
in their image really there's there's a
very French Revolutionary aspect to this
I mean it really sounds a lot like the
Liberals the so-called liberals the
so-called left of the French Revolution
which was a very similar project I think
today's liberals have embraced that big
time and I think what conservatives need
to say is actually the foundations of
American society are very strong the
Dignity of the common person that's what
our country is built on the Dignity of
the ordinary working man and woman that
still is the foundation of this country
the individual liberty uh the idea that
that work is is is has dignity has worth
has value that a family is something
that is a great and Noble pursuit in
life that as a man you can contribute to
your society and make the world a better
place that is a man and woman together
you can build a Haven and a home these
very fundamental foundational things I
really think is what our politics is
about today and the left has no longer
believes those things and I think that
for conservatives it's not just about we
need to improve the economy although we
do because the left is destroying the
American economy especially for working
people but it's really more
fundamentally that we've got to preserve
the foundations of our culture that
allows people to thrive and flourish and
find Liberty
[Music]
government continues to spend borrowed
money inflation continues to swell
dragging down our economy and the stock
market has entered bear territory so
what's your plan are your assets
Diversified I'm Phillip Patrick precious
metal specialist for the Birch gold
group for nearly 20 years we've helped
Americans diversify into gold and we can
help you too did you know you can own
physical gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account we can help you
transfer an IRA or 401K tied to stocks
into an IRA in Gold if you're skeptical
about the trajectory of the economy in
the US dollar then text Jordan to 989898
but Gold group will send you a free info
kit on securing your savings with gold
with thousands of satisfied customers
five star reviews and an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau we take
Precious Metals seriously text Jordan to
989898 for your free info kit
well you know the the the idea that the
US is somehow systemically racist in its
Essence is a accusation that's really
Troublesome to me because I don't just
think that it's merely a lie
I think it's an anti-truth like most
lies are lies that are sort of like
truth but a little bit they have the
details they're modified here and there
so that people can get away with
whatever they're lying about but now and
then you hear a lie so egregious that it
couldn't be farther from the truth and
so what what what I find mysterious
about all this is The credibility of the
claim so we could give the devil is due
and we could say every institutional
structure ever generated by human beings
has a corrupt element and it's corrupted
by let's say the desire for narcissistic
power on behalf of the people who occupy
the structure and since time immemorial
it's been necessary for human beings to
keep an eye on their institutions so
they don't become entirely corrupt but
to point out that a that institutions
contend towards corruption let's say as
a consequence of the inappropriate
expression of power is a very different
thing than to say that the institutions
themselves are built on something
approximating exploitation and then when
I look at the anglo-american tradition
let's say which the U.S firmly sits sits
in the middle of obviously what I see is
the manifestation of the only great
society in human history that's being
essentially anti-slavery and so the
spirit that produced well both Great
Britain in its in its Democratic
manifestation and then out of that the
United States the spirit that's produced
that and the autonomy that's part and
parcel of that is exactly the spirit
that's fought against the status quo of
slavery which is something approximating
human Universal and so I I find it so
utterly preposterous that
this insistence has been put forward
that in its Essence the American
Enterprise is somehow racist and
oppressive even though it might be
contaminated with that as all systems
are so I don't understand why this has
become so
acceptable to people uh
maybe you can expand on that
well you know I think that a couple of
things I mean the first is that there's
a big difference and you've you're
getting at it between thinking of the
founding of the United States let's say
as in 1776 which is indeed when the
country was founded with the Declaration
of Independence in 1619 which is what
the American left now says with their
Infamous 1619 project why did they pick
that day because that's the date that
the slave trade began to be practiced at
scale on the North American continent so
now if you think that
1619 was the true founding of the United
States which you're saying is the
country is founded on the principle of
Oppression the country is founded on the
idea of exploiting some people so that
other people can get ahead and that's
what America is now if you think that's
what America is most fundamentally then
you probably think that America needs to
be fundamentally changed and reformed
and and and overhauled from top to
bottom and and that would explain the
less program because that's what they're
arguing for today well but but if that
is America in its fundament then why
isn't there still slavery
like because look this is the crucial
issue here because look slavery isn't a
mystery the idea that might makes right
and that if I can I can compel you to do
things that you wouldn't otherwise do
using Force that's been a governing
principle of many societies as far back
as we can look in the past
and then recently there's been some
societies who have more or less managed
to escape from that Temptation and
certainly the Western democracies are
first and foremost among those countries
and maybe the U.S and Great Britain
first and foremost among those and so if
it's the case that the U.S was founded
on the principle of enslavement then why
did slavery disappear what what's the
explanation coming from the left for
that
yes and I I think Jordan that that's
you've laid the finger on the problem
with with that world view I mean I think
that what they would probably say is is
that well you you had a a farsighted
Vanguard that realized that the
fundamental tenets of American society
were terribly mistaken and so in order
to correct uh in order to to end the
oppression you have to then introduce
something that is in many ways
fundamentally anti-American this is the
point if you think that the American the
America was founded in 1619 founded on
oppression then the only way to get rid
of the oppression is to do something
that is contrary to America's Traditions
I would argue by contrast if you believe
that the country was founded truly in
1776 upon the principle that all men and
women are endowed with unalienable
rights in Jefferson's phrase from their
creator
well then you have something quite
different and then then we get to what
you were just saying a moment ago then
the story of American History becomes
the story to realize
that principle and of course you know to
in the in the face of uh in the face of
Injustice certainly in the in the face
of of of backsliding if you like but
it's always pushing forward towards that
principle and that that is in fact the
truth which is why why did America
eliminate slavery that's okay okay so
let's let's take that particular tax so
if
slavery is wrong which I think we can
all agree uh is true then we might have
to ask ourselves well on what grounds do
you make the claim that slavery is wrong
and your point with regards to the
founding document the Declaration of
Independence is that there is an axiom
being put forth there that all human
beings men and women alike regardless of
race have some intrinsic inviolable
worth that's associated with the fact
that they're an image of the creative
principle itself the image of the
Creator itself and so that's what's
self-evident and so it's the consequence
of that self-evidence that the moral
claim that slavery is in fact wrong can
be put forth and so that's where the
impetus comes from so if you're opposing
that idea and you say well no the U.S is
based on an alternative anti-slavery
principle and that's generated by this
Vanguard what's the basis for the
derivation of the anti-slavery Prince
principle that hypothetically motivates
the Vanguard where did that come from
because I think that's completely
historically inaccurate if you look
carefully at the manner in which
opposition to slavery made itself
manifest it appears to me that it's part
and parcel of a much older biblical than
British tradition and that is the
flowering of this idea this strange idea
that despite
surface appearances that might be
differences in wealth and Status the
difference between the aristocracy even
and the commoners human beings have an
intrinsic dignity that's not to be
um
that's not to be trifled with certainly
not economically and that's the spirit
that manifested the rise of of democracy
in Great Britain and also the spirit
that animated the
the formation of the US now I don't
understand how you can lay out an
alternative to that so so how do you
think this is being managed on the left
who are these who is this Vanguard is
this Enlightenment rationalists or some
damn thing because that's not going to
fly yeah no I think that is what they
believe I I think they think that uh
that they have true listen I think just
to take a step back you mentioned the
Bible I'm glad since you did because I I
would I would make this the strong claim
that I know is controversial in the in
many quarters of the uh Elite today in
many quarters of the uh that say the
educational establishment in America and
elsewhere that actually the American
tradition of individual liberty the
American tradition of self-government of
individual dignity really runs back to
what I would call the revolution of the
Bible it goes all the way back to the
tradition that comes to us through
Jerusalem and Athens that says that in
fact we are created in the in the image
of a Creator every person has inherent
dignity and worth that was a
revolutionary concept as you know in the
ancient world incredibly disruptive
incredibly disruptive and I would argue
as a historical matter and as a
philosophical matter that great
disruption of the ancient status quo
which was built on power which was built
on status that disruption begins with
the revolution of the Bible and it
ripples through as you said through
through English History British history
through American history and it's really
the foundation the philosophical
foundation of the United States now the
left I think is fundamentally opposed to
that tradition they view that tradition
as oppressive they think it's not a
source of Liberation they think it's a
source of Oppression and so I think much
like the French revolutionaries of the
1700s or for that matter Marx a century
later they think that to to to to uh to
end the oppressive the oppressiveness of
that tradition you've got to in fact
reinvent it that you have to depart from
the Bible but on what principles but on
what principles are you going to
reinvent it well we know how the French
Revolution turned out that wasn't so
good but I mean you make these new
principles out of whole cloth and and
you start with the axiomatic
presupposition for example that slavery
is wrong and that just floats in the air
somehow there's no there's no ground
underneath that I don't this is what I
don't understand is if the if the
radicals on the left are so opposed to
the imposition of arbitrary power let's
say and it's ultimate form about being
slavery then they are standing for
something like the intrinsic Dignity of
the individual and that Principle as far
as I can tell as you just laid out is a
Biblical principle that's where it came
from and I don't see how you any I don't
understand how that can be disputed I
mean you see that for example in the
book of Exodus with the insistence that
there's something intrinsically wrong
with the slavery of people who should be
free even if they don't want to be free
because the Israelites aren't
necessarily that happy about being freed
is that there's something intrinsically
wrong with slavery itself and I think
the intrinsic
um what the intrinsic wrong of slavery
is something like violation of the
principle of the intrinsic Divine worth
of each individual and that is a
Biblical presupposition obviously so I
don't understand I still can't get a
grip on why that would be opposed if the
opposition that's being gen generated is
in fact opposition to slavery itself
why would you go after the spirit that
freed the slaves I don't get that
I I I I think it's a good question and I
I don't know that I have the answer
since I don't hold to that world view
but I think Jordan I think what it
really comes down to is
the left whether we're talking about the
left of of the French Revolution or the
left of today and I I do think that they
share a fundamental animating spirit I
think the left sees any sort of
Authority higher than their own desires
and their own will as fundamentally
oppressive so as soon as you mention the
word god
that becomes a source of Oppression oh
wait a minute there's there's there's
some higher standard than what I want to
do with my life there's some higher
standard than my whims or passions no no
no no no no I'm that's oppressive I'm
I'm being oppressed and so they almost
see the individual as as a
self-sustaining self-generating
self-originating entity the problem with
that is that if if that's true then on
what basis are you going to claim that
all individuals have equal dignity that
no one individual should oppress another
and that we should we should we should
work together in a form of
self-government and common Liberty I
mean it gets to the problem that you've
been talking about but I I think it's
the idea really of God if we're coming
right down to it oh well I I was just
thinking about the argument that could
be laid forth on the conservative front
with regards to a vision that might be
attractive let's say to young people
because one of the things that I've
noticed on my tours in particular
talking to young people about
the meaning that can be derived from
life that can sustain you through
tragedy is that that's not found in an
atomistic subjectively defined
liberalism and there's an interesting
clinical element to this so we know that
thoughts that are associated with
self-consciousness
are
statistically indistinguishable from
experiences of negative emotion
so it's literally the case that the more
you think about yourself
the more unhappy you are unhappy anxious
grief-strick and frustrated
disappointment disappointed hurt
and so then you think well where did
people find the meaning that helps them
abide through tragedy and turn their
attention away from themselves and the
answer is well we don't even have to
introduce God into the picture at the
moment you say well
you find a fair bit of that sustaining
meaning through reciprocal relationships
you want to have an intimate
relationship of some duration or it's
just a
series of short-term psychopathically
narcissistic pit stops which don't seem
to do anyone any good so you want to
have an intimate relationship of some
duration you probably want to have a
family at least
to have some contact with your parents
and your siblings and perhaps even
children if you dare to do that likely
you need some friends you probably need
something approximating a job or a
career you have to be nested inside a
series of superordinate social
structures in order to be a functioning
individual at all
and so I think conservatives can to
offer a rejoinder to the Liberals and
say you
you are assuming that individual
autonomy is a higher good only because
for centuries the individual was so
ensconced and superordinate social
Community by default that you could just
ignore that that existed and now we
can't do that anymore because people are
so fractionated that they're abandoning
well marriage they're abandoning family
they're abandoning friendship I suppose
in favor of its virtual alternative and
that's catastrophic
and I think young people know this
I agree with that and and I think that
there's a message
that young people want to hear Jordan
which is that their lives can matter and
that their sacrifices can matter and
that you find meaning in life
not So Much by what you gain but by what
you give up it's not so much by what you
accrue to yourself but it's what you
give away to other people it's who it's
who you choose to serve what you choose
to spend your life on and I think what
modern liberalism tells people is demand
your rights demand entitlements demand
the Fulfillment of your desires what
conservatives should be saying is go and
find somebody to serve go and find
something greater than yourself to be
part of go and give your life to
something and as you do you'll find that
you are able to to make the world around
you a better place and you don't do that
by by again accruing things to yourself
you don't do that by by piling up more
rights you do that by giving yourself
away in a sense which is I think a very
fundamental truth that every husband
knows every father knows and I think
that that's something that that young
people want to hear they want to be
called to something greater than
themselves and liberalism just doesn't
offer that liberalism is is at the end
of the day it's a cult of satisfying
your own desire whatever it may be today
and at least people fundamentally alone
adrift and isolated well that that
that
it satisfies the liberal ethos satisfies
what you want today or what you want at
this moment and that also makes it
shallow in a non-sustainable way because
I think that if you treat yourself
properly which might be part of a more
mature liberal ethos let's say then
you're not a prisoner of each momentary
whim and the reason for that is that all
that happens if you are that is that you
betray yourself and so we know for
example that Psychopaths who are
motivated by power and very manipulative
and who are in it for the gratification
of their own whims do very badly across
any reasonable length of time they're
completely incapable of learning from
experience technically and what that
means is they constantly betray
themselves and so if you're pursuing an
Impulse of Hedonism then to hell with
you tomorrow fundamentally and next week
and next year you continue to do things
that are pleasurable or Escapist in the
moment but all it does is drive you
downhill across time because you should
treat yourself as a community that
extends across time
and so and I do think that young people
are continuing onto this in a major way
and it is something that conservatives
can lay out in great detail and this
idea about giving
you know even if you do want the best
for yourself in some higher sense let's
say yourself across time it's clearly
the case that
the most effective way to achieve that
is to be unbelievably useful and
generous to other people because there
are a lot of other people and so if
you're interacting with them in a manner
that is let's say self-sacrificing in a
reciprocal Manner and generous then
they're going to want to interact with
you and so if you interact with a
thousand people in your life and you're
generous to all them and they
reciprocate then you're the beneficiary
of a thousand acts of generosity a
thousand continual sets of Acts of
generosity how can that not be a better
approach than trying to maximize your
momentary whim let's say I think that's
exactly right and I think that today in
in our in our contemporary culture
United States at least Jordan today
because of the rise of of Technology big
Tech social media the problem is not
that uh young people feel that that they
can't that they're too
um that they're too enmeshed in
community that there are too many people
who care about them it's not that they
feel smothered it's that they feel
totally isolated because they don't
they're losing face-to-face contact with
friends they're losing meaningful
relationships I mean they feel isolated
they feel alone they feel alienated and
we know this is true because if you look
at the the statistics where people tell
pollsters in terms of the feeling of
isolation what we see from from
treatment of depression what we see from
suicide in the United States suicide
rates in the United States among
unfortunately all demographics but
particularly young people particularly
young men are are rising to levels that
we haven't seen in the country really
ever and this should tell us that
there's something that is fundamentally
amiss with the sort of culture of
self-gratification that liberalism has
on offer that people want more than that
they sense that there is more to life
than that they want to be connected with
something greater than themselves well
you talked about young men there and and
their despair I mean if your culture is
telling you constantly that all of your
ambition is either part of the
patriarchal process of Oppression and
Corruption
and that even if you manage something
despite that particular cost to
criticism then everything ambitious you
ever do is only contributing to the
despoiling of the planet then you have a
uh a story about social interaction that
is predicated on the assumption that
every single kind of social structure
marriage friendship all of that
certainly employment Civic engagement
political uh political Endeavor that's
nothing but the manifestation of the
brute Will To Power it's no wonder that
would make you cynical especially if
you're actually ethical because you
might think well I don't want to be
corrupt and I don't want to be a
corrupted spoiler so I just won't do
anything and and then well then of
course you don't do anything and all you
do under those circumstances is suffer
and it's so corrosive and and acidic
that critique again you could say well
when relationships deteriorate they
deteriorate in the Gen in the direction
of narcissistic expression of power but
that doesn't mean at all ever that the
basis for any relationship is power I
don't think there's any evidence for
that at all I think it's a completely
Preposterous claim and My worry is is
that what the left with the modern left
leaves us with Jordan is really nothing
more than the narcissistic expression of
power My worry is that as the left's
program has has come to take root as
they've attacked these cultural
institutions like the family like the
church uh like even the local
neighborhood as they have as they have
attacked the very idea of finding your
life in sacrifice and service to others
what are we left with we're left with
whoever has the most options and the
most power is the most free what are we
left with we're left with a new
hierarchy in the United States which is
if you have an advanced degree and can
earn a lot of money then you are the
best and you have the most choices in
life and you are the most valuable
member of society if if you're not if if
you are not somebody who who wants to go
get a four-year college degree if you
don't earn a lot of money then you're
somehow less than you're lesser so what
we end up with is a a hierarchy of
elitism a hierarchy of educational
attainment a hierarchy of status and
this I would argue is what happens when
you take away the idea that every
individual has fundamental worth and
dignity that every individual is created
in the image of God and that every
individual finds his or her ultimate
purpose and meaning in serving others
and so my my concern is is that even as
the left attacks American tradition and
cultural institutions as being
oppressive what they actually give us
through their campaign of cultural
nihilism is a form of hierarchy and
elitism and of course also expanding
government government control government
super supervision government
surveillance you know as people
abandoned their subsidiary social
organizations so you abandon your
long-term
marital commitment you abandoned your
decision to have children you abandoned
your willingness to engage in reciprocal
friendships you don't shoulder your
civic duty you isolate yourself in your
job in your career all of that
responsibility that you undertake is
then vacuumed up by people who will use
it
for the purposes of their own power
that that's definitely the case I mean
you see this with the emerging tyranny
let's say and pathology at levels of
Civic organization like the school
boards where
ordinary people who share a common
Vision have abdicated their
responsibility for these mid-level
bureaucracies and they're instantly
invaded by people who are ideologically
possessed and power mad and so another
useful message for young people is that
if you don't take on the responsibility
that's commensurate with a properly
integrated life then tyrants will take
all that responsibility from you and use
it to in the name of the maintenance of
oppressive power you have atomized
individuals in a centralized State
that's all they'll be left exactly and
by the way that's a historical pattern
we saw that pattern with the French
Revolution right I mean we it in the
name of of Liberty fraternity equality
what do we end up with you ended up with
the terror which was managed by just a
very few people and then you ended up
ultimately with Napoleon I mean you talk
about an oppressive dictatorship that
happens when you when you take away the
those institutions that actually gather
together
individuals that that pool if you like
individual sovereignty and that act as a
way in which the individual expresses
himself or herself you know the other
thing I would say about modern America
Jordan is this is that if you believe
like the left says that modern American
society is systemically corrupt and
oppressive and all the rest
the question becomes well who's going to
remake it and the left's answer is the
government the government's going to
remake it you know the government is
going to use the power of the state
which is the power of coercion to
fundamentally change this society and I
just argue to you that's what Joe Biden
has been doing if you want to know why
the Biden Administration is putting
their diversity inclusion and Equity
agenda into every nook and cranny of the
federal government that's why if you
want to know why they're turning the FBI
loose on parents who complain at school
board meetings that's why they are
willing to use and eager to use the
power of the state to try and change
what they believe is the oppressive
nature of American society and I the
danger of that the coerciveness of that
I think is hugely hugely alarming
why do you think that a
remedial Vision has been lacking so
intensely on the conservative side and
then so that's question number one and
question number two do you see a a
reactionary Danger
emerging on the side of the reactionary
right
yeah I think that yes on the second
question yes I mean I think that what we
have to be careful of is
you've got the left that wants to it
really in a sense burn it all down
metaphorically speaking although for
some of the riots that we saw in in for
instance 2020 it's not metaphorical at
all I mean they really are willing to to
torch buildings and and and storm
government centers and salt cops and so
on but you've got this this Spirit of
nihilism on the left and I think it is
the danger on the right is we mustn't
react with a concomitant the spirit of
nihilism ourselves where we say yeah
that's right it's all corrupt it's all
destroyed it's all worthless we've got
to completely start over no no no no no
no no no what we want to say is what we
should be saying is no America actually
the fund the foundations of this country
is fundamentally good it's fundamentally
sound does there need to be reform yeah
of course there does I mean it's it's
the berkian point right a society
without the means of change is that
without the means of its conservation
and it's preservation so yeah there's
corruption that needs to be addressed
there are reforms that need to be made
uh there's I would argue we're seeing in
the bite Administration deep corruption
in many levels of our government but the
foundations of our of our system our
constitution our philosophical beliefs
going back to the the foundations of the
biblical tradition those are not only
sound
those are the things that make America
America and I think for conservatives
our vision has to be centered around
preserving those and returning those to
their rightful place and so it's not
it's it's not a campaign of nihilism
it's a campaign of building up it's a
campaign of saying that listen we
Americans are proud of thinking that
we're the greatest country in the
history of the world I think that and if
you believe that
you've got to put forward an agenda
that's about returning and strengthening
the foundations of America's strength
and I think that's what conservatives
should be for we've got to resist the
siren song of saying yeah we'll join the
left and just burn it all down that I
think is dangerous this is one of the
things that has been perturbing me about
the
and we could we could talk again about
the midterms and maybe about the 2024
presidential election what I see
happening on the right on the Trump side
in particular and it's quite shocking to
me in some sense is that The Narrative
seems to be that the institutions are so
corrupt that even the Democratic process
itself can no longer be trusted and the
problem I see on that front is that it
does first of all it plays against the
Trump brand as far as I can tell because
Trump was the guy who didn't have things
stolen from him and who came out
Victorious even if he was confronted by
tyranny itself he can deal with people
like Kim Jong-un and and Vladimir Putin
no problem
um and so for him to claim that the
country was pulled out from underneath
him seems to me to be off-brand but even
more dangerous is that it leads to this
kind of corrosive cynicism about the
fundamental utility of institutions in
the United States and that does play
into the hands of the radicals whether
they are right or left-wing and so
um so I would like you to comment about
that
um and because it seems to me the
Republican party in some sense is
tearing itself apart over the uh over
the election issue and and then I would
also like your opinion about why there
is a swing towards the Republicans in
this midterm and who and who is at the
Forefront of that swing
yeah let me start with the first I I
think that
as I talked to conservative voters I
represent the state of Missouri as you
said at the beginning and as I talk to
to Folks at home
the thing that concerns me most and and
where I I I think the the the spirit we
have to guard against is when people say
you know I just am so
I am so upset and I am so distraught
over what's happening in our country I
just don't think it's worth it anymore I
don't think that what I do anymore
matters I don't think my vote matters
anymore uh I I just I just don't think
it matters and so I just I just am
willing to give up that I think is a
very alarming
um and ultimately of course self
self-fulfilling uh attitude and and one
I think we've got to combat against and
what I always say is listen that this
this is a democracy I mean at the end of
the day let me put it to you this way
Theodore Roosevelt who is one of my
Boyhood Heroes Theodore Roosevelt once
said that in America we're not ruled
over by other people in America every
man and woman is a sovereign and so we
have the responsibilities that a
sovereign would have there is something
that is extremely dignifying about that
and also very true and I think that in
this moment of turmoil in the United
States what we have to say in
conservatives especially has to say is
this is a time for we the American
people to stand up and to take seriously
our responsibilities as the sovereigns
of this nation we've got to make
decisions and act and engage in a way
that is going to be for the benefit of
the country that's going to work toward
a future that we want to see so it's got
to be pro-engagement not disengagement
it's got to be toward reforming our
institutions not destroying them and by
the way I don't I don't think
conservative voters I mean I listen to
my voters at home you don't hear that
they're not the ones who are saying oh
this country is corrupt they don't
believe that they think the country is
good they think the country's badly LED
and they're right about that but the
solution to that is not to say we give
up we withdraw the solution to that is
to press in and say we're going to make
change we're going to engage in the
Democratic process we're going to go
forward and I think that that's key the
second thing about the midterms
I was struck Jordan recently I read
something by a democratic pollster a guy
who's a really sharp guy and and uh his
name is David Shore and I'm sure he
would not like me praising him because
that's probably terrible for his
reputation but uh he's he he's a liberal
let's be very clear about this a
political liberal but uh he's a very
smart analyst work for President Obama
former President Obama and something
that he said recently really caught my
attention because I think it's right he
says that everywhere around the the
industrialized world the the so-called
developed world and every country in
which the left party
has emphasized cultural and social
change cultural and social uh critique
much as the left in America has in fact
and everywhere where they've elevated
this idea that the foundations of
Western Society are fundamentally
oppressive and illegitimate in every
single instance
the working people of the country have
moved towards the right why is that
because the working people of the
country don't believe that the working
people of the country want to preserve
their culture and their Liberties they
don't want it taken from them in reform
so what does that have to do with the
midterms I think Republicans why are
Republicans benefiting from from the
swing away from Biden it's because Joe
Biden is out there saying in word and
deed that American society needs to be
overhauled and I think that the people
of this country and I keep saying
working people is in contrast to the
more educated Elite because you know the
educated Elite uh at the products of our
of our educational system Elite
educational system
uh they increasingly are are part of
they they take the left liberal view but
I think the working people this country
they say no this my cult my family I I
believe in family
Church synagogue I believe in those
things I want my neighborhood to be safe
I want my kids to be taught in school to
love America not to hate America I want
them to be tough that individual liberty
is good not fundamentally oppressive and
they see these things they say I'm going
to vote for somebody who will keep my
family safe who will preserve these
institutions and who will give me a shot
to make something of myself in life and
I think if the Republicans in this
country can open their eyes and
understand that's why voters are coming
to them then we can begin to craft an
agenda that responds to that if they
think that voters are coming to them for
just about any other reason I think that
they're I think they're not paying
attention
yeah well you're seeing this swing to a
more conservative ethos in all sorts of
places all at the same time it's
happened in Italy it looks like it's
going to happen in France it happened in
Sweden of all places
and so
and now with the flip in the midterms it
looks like it's happening in the U.S
and so this is an opportunity for for
conservatives to put forward a
alternative vision and one that seems to
be focused on responsibility strikes me
as the right rejoinder to the left's
constant clamoring about rights the
thing is rights are always obtained at
the expense of someone else in some
sense if you only concentrate on rights
because every person's rights is the
collective's responsibility let's say or
each individual's responsibility and the
other issue that you brought up is
something like the Dignity of work and
service and if it's all about your
rights and not about your responsibility
and the meaning in your life is actually
attendant on the responsibility then all
that clamoring for rights just makes you
makes your life devoid of any purposeful
meaning and that strikes me as highly
probable given that most purpose is
equivalent in some sense to
self-sacrifice
to have a purpose is to go do something
right not just to sit around and wait in
some sense for some kind of
instantaneous trivial gratification but
to strive forward
for something worth attaining and and
that is that is always in the domain of
responsibility and I think that the left
and the right when it comes to the
subject of Rights I think the left and
the right have a fundamentally different
view about rights the the right says
that what the Declaration of
Independence says is true that our
rights come to us
by virtue of the fact that we're made in
the image of God our rights come to us
because they're given by God and our
rights by the way point us toward our
responsibilities we have rights
that that open up to us fields of action
where we're supposed to serve you know
we have the right to follow our
conscience for example you know what is
that really well that that says that
that we're obligated to follow the truth
and that as we feel as we understand the
truth you know what was it Lincoln said
I mean I will follow the riot as God
gives me to see the right you know that
that is it is a right but it is also a
responsibility that's the rights view
our view conservative view of
responsibility of Rights rather the left
the left view is well actually rights
are are uh entitlements that come to you
from the state and so therefore the
state needs to expand its power for you
to have more rights and the problem with
that Jordan is is that it what the real
message to individuals is you're weak
and in need of help from the state you
know you're fundamentally weak the state
needs to help you by giving you all of
these things by taking care of you by
giving you these rights the conservative
message needs to be you're not weak you
you are strong you have the capacity in
yourself to do something to change the
world to contribute to society and let's
get up and do it let's go do something
together let's go let's get up there and
actually give ourselves to a cause
greater than ourselves I think you look
at that difference that's a very
fundamental one and it results in a very
different program for America do you
want to strengthen people to go dive
into their responsibilities to shoulder
more responsibility to be able to do
more on their own or do you want
government to take care of them while
government by the way fundamentally
reforms Society yeah well I suppose it
depends on whether or not you think that
people are victims or citizens
and if they're victims then they have to
have their their oppression remediated
and it would require a central authority
to manage that and of course that should
be the alarm Bell right there it's well
why in the world are you going to trust
a centralizing Authority when you have
every reason not to and alternatively
you could say well life is difficult
there's no doubt about that and some
people are dealt worse hands than others
in some ways but that doesn't mean that
you can't put your best foot forward in
service and find the meaning in your
life in pushing back against that which
enshackles you let's say
and that strikes me as highly probable
and psychologically appropriate and also
a very marketable message especially to
young men now you're also writing a book
at the moment on manhood that's right
we've talked about that briefly well so
tell me about that and tell me why
you're doing that well I'm I'm writing
it because as I I look out at the
problem of at the plight of men in
America
you know it's just what you what you see
Jordan in the numbers is you see that
men are uh increasingly turning away
from work they're increasingly turning
away from education let's take some
numbers I mean since 1965 in the United
States there are 500 percent more men
who are out of able-bodied men I should
stipulate able-bodied men of working age
who are out of the labor force that
means not even trying to look for a job
500 percent more now than there were in
1965. that is an astounding number you
look at the number of men who are
pursuing education both high school
education and higher education it's
collapsing right now in the United
States it is 60 40 female to male
enrollment in colleges that's great
that's great for women but for men well
it's great for women unless they're
looking for a man in which case it's not
so great either a partner I've heard
recent statistics suggesting that when
the ratio of men to women goes lower
than 65 35 sorry women to men lower than
65 35 5 the women stopped going to
college too
wow well so we may soon find out because
yeah is is down down for male
participation you look at male suicide
rates you look at male drug abuse all of
these things would suggest that there is
a pathology or series of pathologies
that is afflicting men in the United
States and maybe particularly young men
in the United States and I think this is
one of the biggest challenges that we
face as a society so I I wanted to to
think about that I wanted to do my part
to try and say something constructive
about it and I think Jordan one of the
big things is is that I think men don't
often have a vision anymore for their
lives as to what their lives could be
and they're told and you referenced it a
minute ago they're told incessantly from
the time that they are in grade school
that they are part of the problem and
that if they try to go out and and be a
contributor to society if they go out
and try to exert any kind of leadership
in in any field or Endeavor that they
contribute to the patriarchy that they
contribute to the climate disaster as
the so-called climate disaster as you
said earlier that they contribute to the
systemic injustices of America this is
the constant message to men and I think
that that's fundamentally untrue and we
should be saying something to men that's
very different we should be saying to
them that this country needs you that
your families need you that your
neighborhoods need you that you can make
the world a better place and you were
born to do that and so what I try to do
in in the book is I try to go back all
the way back to the very beginning back
to the Bible back to Genesis and say
what does that begin to open up for us
this very foundational story what does
it open up for us about what a man is
supposed to be and if you look at the
Book of Genesis and what God calls Adam
to do he calls Adam to work with him to
help finish the world to help perfect
the world and bring it into Perfection
you know and not to get too deep into
the details here but you know if you
look at Genesis 1 and 2 what the Garden
of Eden really is in many ways is it is
a temple and what it's a temple where
God dwells and Adam is there and Eve too
cooperating working with God that's the
symbolism of it what is supposed to
happen Adam is supposed to work with God
to make the rest of the world a temple
to to expand the garden if you like to
make the world beautiful to make the
world what it could be to bring the
world into further into Perfection and
to work with God to do that now that I
would suggest to you that's a pretty
high calling that suggests that wow a
man can really make a difference in life
that a man has a has a high calling in
life that's a vision you could give
yourself to and sacrifice for when I've
been going around the world
uh doing these talks I think I've done
60 since January something like that in
different cities all around the United
States and Canada and Europe
I meet about 150 people after each
each lecture or each question and answer
period and
they're very very positive events and
the fundamental reason that they're
positive is because first of all most of
the people who come are dressed up it's
kind of like a wedding reception so lots
of the young men who come and young
women too because more and more the
young men who are coming have partners
with them who look quite happy to be
with them they're dressed quite formally
and so they all look like adults and
they're all standing up straight which
is really lovely to see and you know
they're they're kind of a well put
together bunch and they they talk to me
not for very long because it takes a
while to beat 150 people but I get a few
fractions of a minute with each person
and the it's very moving
because
they tell me variants of the same story
which is something like
you know I've been
listening to your lectures for five or
six years and I wasn't doing very well
back then I was pretty nihilistic I
didn't think there was much point to my
life I was I wasn't really you know
pursuing my education or working I
didn't have a partner things looked
pretty bleak for me and then I decided I
was gonna put some effort into it you
know and straighten up a bit and stop
lying that's a big one I was going to
start telling the truth and I was going
to start shouldering my responsibility
and I was going to try to get a partner
and be someone for that partner and
start a family and so forth and you know
what
it's really working things are so much
better for me that I can hardly believe
it and and then you know if their
partner's there she's usually pretty
happy with the whole situation too and
often they're getting engaged or they've
just got married or they have to have
their first child because now they've
decided to have children they I can meet
all these people who are getting a life
and it's so
heartening that it's well that's why my
wife and I continue to do it I travel
around the world and what's so sad about
this as far as I I'm concerned is that
these young men didn't need that much
encouragement to get out there and get
at it they just needed some
encouragement or at least maybe they
needed at least one person who wasn't
actively telling them every second that
every single shred of ambition they
might manifest is nothing but the
pathology that drives tyranny and the
raping force that destroys the planet
yeah so I I yep enough of that man
really like enough of that
agreed agreed I I think we we need to
send a fundamentally different message
which is that their lives look the the
world will not be what it could be
without them I think that's the I think
that's the message by the way I think
that's the message of the of the Bible I
think that's the message of of our of
American History it's that the the world
there are things that can be done in the
world things that should be done in the
world that only you can do and that if
you don't do them they won't happen and
the world and the people around it your
your family your your your spouse your
children they will be impoverished if
you don't shoulder the responsibility
that you could shoulder that's a high
Vision that's a high calling by the way
that's true of our country our country
will be less if you don't take on the
obligations of citizenship this country
can be greater it can be more with you
as part of it and it won't be what it
could be without you we need you and I I
think that is the message Mindy to hear
yeah well I and I think that's true is
that to the degree that each person is
unique and their each person is unique
to a great degree then each person has
something to bring into the world that
only they could bring into it and that's
literally the case and I do believe that
that's part parcel of the idea that
human beings are made in the image of
God is God is presented in the biblical
Corpus as the fundamental creative force
of of reality itself and that's echoed
inside of us and so if we don't bring
forth what is within us then there's a
lack in the structure of reality and
that lock produces undue pain and misery
and suffering and so it is the case that
each person needs to shoulder the
responsibility for improving the garden
you might say as you pointed out earlier
or working towards the perfect ability
of existence itself and that's a heavy
load for each person to bear too because
it turns out that it isn't true that
nothing you do matters what's true is
that everything you do matters a lot
more than you think and you should get
the hell out of it now because uh or or
else in some sense you know the other
thing we know as a consequence of having
blundered our way through the entire
20th century is that when people do
abdicate their responsibility on Moss
which is what you saw in well Nazi
Germany what you saw in totalitarian
Soviet Union and in Mao's China that
things turn into hell very very rapidly
yeah that's right and and this goes back
to a point that you've made Jordan that
I think is is exactly right and I think
is is just deeply true is that we can
either be moving the world to be more
like what it should be we can make it a
little bit more like heaven or we can
make it more like hell and and it we're
going to do one or the other and so if
we abdicate our response if men abdicate
their responsibilities if they create a
vacuum then you've got to expect that
malign forces will come into that vacuum
and will do terrible things which is
what we saw in the 20th century on the
other hand if men will shoulder their
responsibility and be faithful father
faithful husbands faithful fathers
strong workers uh and by the way these
don't have to be dramatic things I mean
I think that the our world is so ordered
that even Small Things even small acts
of faithfulness small acts of sacrifice
small acts of constructive work have
huge effects over time in our own lives
and the lives of people around so it's
not as if you don't have to go cure
cancer in order to make a difference
there only small if you're blind all
those all those there's not nothing
that's done right is small
so really and I really believe that's
the case in in the therapeutic process
when you're working with someone as a
behavioral therapist
you almost always help them initiate
small Transformations but first of all
that small transformation often means a
reversal of Direction and a reversal of
Direction isn't small it it couldn't be
more different to go 180 degrees in the
opposite direction that's a big change
and just because you start small doesn't
mean you end up going slow especially if
the consequence is that with each
Victory you accrue in the New Direction
the next step is likely to more likely
to occur and in a larger manner you get
that power loss starting to kick in so
that you don't improve linearly you
improve exponentially once you start
moving forward and so I think the
smallness of right action is only a
consequence of a kind of of an
inappropriate perspective that assumes
that the local and daily is minimally
important when there's no evidence
for that at all I mean you can think
about this this way to some degree
the most intense
relationships that you're going to have
in your life are local the relationship
you have with your wife and with your
child and you might think well that's
only my child it's not every child in
the world it's only my wife it's not
every woman in the world but that local
Focus has an intensity
that is truly indicative of its
significance I would say and so the that
that's another reason why conservatives
can help people put the local back in
in a superordinate position it's like it
isn't only that your family matters
it it's it's that your family matters
more than anything else and that's
appropriate it's not that you're
abdicating your social responsibility
that way as you're manifesting your true
social responsibility through your
intense engagement with the local and
that might mean you're a dishwasher so
you get the hell out of bed and you show
up to work 15 minutes early so the
restaurant can run properly and that's
not trivial
it and if you think it's trivial it's
because there's something wrong with
your attitude not because it's trivial
in and of itself
and I think that the I think that that
presenting men with a with a vision
again young men in particular with a
vision that says that yeah even those
things getting to work early
um doing something kind for somebody uh
being faithful to your partner those
things
can can literally change the fabric of
the universe you're working on the
fabric of the world and doing these
things and you are making the world more
of what it could be that's a high
calling it's a noble calling and I just
think that that kind of vision the the
the leftist rhetoric I think suppresses
and destroys that sort of vision and it
therefore suppresses and destroys a
healthy ambition and instead what it
substitutes is a desire just to fulfill
momentary pleasure to indulge momentary
whims and I think that's what you see a
lot of unfortunately a lot of a lot of
young men doing and there's one other
aspect of this Jordan that gets to a
gets to more of a policy issue that I
think conservatives in a political sense
need to address in this country in the
United States
a lot of men
who don't have an advanced college
degree or a four-year college degree
their economic prospects in terms of the
kind of job that they can get in terms
of their ability to support a family are
are severely diminished and have been
getting worse over decades conservatives
if they're going to call men to
responsibility and we should if they're
going to say that that you can you we
need you we've also at the same time got
to say we need to have a society and an
economy that provides you with
productive work on which you can sustain
a family that there is a legitimate shot
for you to go out there get a job get
married have a family and sustain them
if you will work hard and apply yourself
and conservatives need to be about
crafting that kind of an economy and I
worry Jordan that part of what's
happened in the last 30 and 40 years is
we've increasingly had an economy that's
in the United States has become hyper
globalized that works for a a small set
of people it's the people who have
advanced degrees in certain sectors and
does not work for the vast majority of
the rest of the population and does not
work for a lot of working-class men and
that's tied up with this and I think
conservatives have got to open their
eyes and say we've got to go out and say
we need a society and an economy that is
going to be able to support work support
a family and you can't be pro-family
unless you're Pro an economy where you
can actually support a family yeah well
it's a form of regulatory capture by the
intellectual Elite that's right that's
right and also you know this this the
the globalist agenda
which is really a an elite project you
know it's it's a project to people who
don't believe in Nations who don't
believe in the local community who don't
believe in local Traditions what they
believe is is they think that that uh
their uh that their values which they
share with other educated Elite around
the country that around the world rather
that those ought to be what structures
the world those ought to be what
structures the economy they pursued this
agenda of hyper globalism that has in
the United States
have resulted in shipping working-class
jobs overseas shutting down jobs that
were good paying jobs and small towns
like the one that I grew up in and it
has really decimated not just the
economic fortunes of many many men and
women too but it is also badly damaged
the fabric the social fabric of this
country and so part of what I think
conservatives in America need to do is
we need to say listen we're going to be
for an agenda that is
unapologetically
pro-american worker unapologetically
pro-work and unapologetically toward for
the kind of work that you can support a
family on and we've got to make some
changes in order to do that and what do
you what kind of changes what kind of
changes do you think might need to be
made at the political level in order
let's say that the goal was to foster
a working man's commitment to his family
and to his to his job and to the
advancement of his career let's say
through that job what sort of
transformations of policy do you think
might be helpful at the level of detail
to facilitate that kind of vision
yeah I think the first thing is we've
got to we've got to be able to give to
give that man
some prospect that if he actually will
get a good if he'll get a job if he'll
commit himself to work if he'll show up
as you said and he'll invest himself
that he'll be able to to support himself
into advance in order to do that Jordan
we've got to get jobs back into the
United States of America where we
actually produce things and make things
where a guy who does not have a college
degree and listen only 35 percent of
Americans have a four-year college
degree or more right and a decreasing
percentage of men are going to have that
as well that is correct and so you know
you're looking at almost 70 percent
let's say of men I think it's more than
70 percent of the workforce does not
have a four-year college degree we have
to have an economy where a man can get a
good paying job so how do we do that we
have to bring production back to the
United States Jordan we've got to bring
we've got to produce things here we've
got to grow things here let me give you
an example men the average salary of a
manufacturing type job in the United
States of a production type job a year
or two ago was 20 I think it was 22.50
was the average hourly wage 22.50 in
retail the average hourly wage is like
13 bucks
in Services it's slightly higher but not
much the point is is that manufacturing
jobs production jobs historically pay
better you could support a family on
those they have a and but they they
drive research and development by the
way they drive the services industry and
what's happened in this country is I
think we've had we've had a
conservatives unfortunately Republicans
have been part of this problem big part
of it we've had a stupid economic policy
that for 30 and 40 years or longer has
said we're willing to see Jobs go
overseas to places like China
we are willing to trade away our
manufacturing and our production of all
kinds whether we're talking about
Precision tooling or whether we're
talking about Advanced farming we're
willing to see those things go away
in order to get more cheap stuff from
overseas and in order to build up a
services and Wall Street driven economy
I think that has been a fundamental
fundamental mistake and conservatives
need to change it and you asked about
Paul how do we do it one of the things
we've got to do is we have got to set a
a a tariff policy and a trade policy
that actually works for America and I
think that that works for American
workers and as geared Jordan towards
bringing back and fostering good paying
production jobs in this country so that
that is a different way of thinking than
most Republicans in the United States
have thought for the last 30 or 40 years
where they've been very
pro-globalization and I think that it's
hard to be pro-globalization and
pro-family pro worker at the same time
tell me more about the book that you're
writing and and and what you're hoping
to accomplish with regards to your
communication to man and why are you
writing a book and and and in instead of
concentrating let's say or in addition
to concentrating on the political issues
well I think it's a matter of both and I
mean I I
think that um
I I will it's it's imperative talk about
the kind of policy issues that we were
just talking about just now to go out
there and to advance legislation and to
advance a policy agenda and I'm
certainly going to do that but I do
think
that it's important right now in
American culture to put forward an
alternative vision of what a man can be
and what what good a man can contribute
and I think the real need is here is
when men are beat over the head as we
talked about from the time they're in
grade school and listen I say this
because I've got two I've got three kids
I've got two little boys a nine-year-old
and a seven-year-old and then I've got a
baby daughter
and you know as a as the father of
parent of a the parent of school-aged
kids is school-aged boys I pay a lot of
attention now to what my kids are taught
in school and to what other kids are
taught in school of course I hear it
from parents who I represent all the
time so I think in this in this cultural
milia where you have the left in control
of many of the of the cultural
institutions the the media much of the
entertainment industry increasingly the
the corporate Suites the the head
offices the Relentless message to men is
that you're a problem uh male ambition
is bad and I think that we need to
present conservatives need to present an
alternative vision and I think that we
need to to show men what what a
different kind of of a vision for
manhood could look like and that's
really what the book is about is trying
to do that
so okay on the on the Republican front
back again to the midterms there is a
swing in the Republican Direction who's
at the Forefront of the Swing who who is
it that's that's whose votes are moving
at the moment and why
well who's really moving our our working
class uh folks
um both uh men and women but
particularly working class men and uh
and across by the way uh different
racial demographics which you see is
working class Hispanic men uh working
class African-American men particularly
younger working class African-American
men and then a working class of white
men are moving in a in a big way towards
the Republican party this actually
really started with Donald Trump in
2016. uh you saw an acceleration of it
in 2020 with uh Trump among voters who
were Hispanic working-class voters and
African-American working-class voters
and especially men and you see the same
thing continuing and maybe even
accelerating in the midterm so there's a
big switch and Jordan it's a huge change
for the Republican party in my lifetime
I'm 42. it's a big change in my lifetime
where right now increasingly the base of
the Republican Party in the United
States is working class voters Blue
Collar voters we often say in America
and and that that hasn't that has not
been the case for most of my lifetime
and I think right now what you're seeing
is Republican leaders are having a hard
time wrapping their heads around that
right you see this to a certain extent
Britain too in Canada as well that's
interesting yeah well a lot of the a lot
of the uh Groundswell of support for the
new conservative leader here Pierre
pauliev who's likely to be the new next
prime minister
God willing is that um there's been a
big swing by younger working-class
people to the conservative party and
that's certainly something that's always
been a big business party in Canada this
is definitely a new thing and so yeah as
you said it's happening in the UK and
the us as well so interesting eh because
hypothetically the left stands for the
oppressed and the voiceless and yet you
see a migration of working-class people
to the Republican Party especially
especially young men which sort of
belies the idea that the left I mean the
left historically at least insofar as it
had its roots in the labor movement I
think was sporadically at least a
Genuine Voice for the for the labor
movement but the fact that all the
working-class people are stampeding over
to the conservative side seems to
indicate in some fundamental sense that
the left has lost the plot
I think in the United States certainly
the left Jordan if you just look at you
look at their their voting returns
the Democrat party today is increasingly
the party of the extremely well-educated
and the upper class in this country I
mean that's it's just a fact you could
just go look at the exit polls and you
see that increasingly the base of that
party
are folks who have at least four-year
degrees or Advanced degrees folks who
make uh above working-class wages up
middle class and really upper middle
class that is the base now of the
Democrat Party and this gets back to the
cultural stuff that segment and it's an
increasingly narrow segment of American
society they tend to buy into all of the
leftist stuff about how systemically
unjust America is what you have is the
vast swath of the American public that
says that's not true and particularly
working people say no no no no no that
is not true and by the way if you if you
destroy the family and if you destroy
the community and you destroy the local
church the local synagogue you're going
to destroy all of my my opportunities in
life and if you keep shipping my jobs
overseas you're going to destroy my
Economic Opportunity in life and I think
that is the the new sort of center of
the Republican part needs to be the
Republican Party in the United States
but the real challenge for us Jordan is
wrapping our heads around that and
getting a set of policies that respond
to the reality of where voters are are
and you mentioned big business a second
ago my own view is that the Republican
Party particularly the last 20 years has
been too enthralled to Big Business you
know big business is in many ways an
increasingly maligned force in America
listen I'm I'm a free market guy I'm a
capitalist uh I believe in in robust
competition but I don't really believe
in Monopoly in fact I don't believe in
Monopoly at all and I believe
increasingly many of these businesses in
the United States huge multinational
corporations they have Monopoly status
they're also woke and so they're pushing
an agenda of economic control and an
agenda of social control at the same
time Republicans I think need to go out
and say no to both of those things yeah
well that's a very that's a very fascist
combination economic control and social
political control at the same time
and so what do you what do you think's
what do you think's driven the emergence
of these larger scale collusionary
monopolies
well I think a couple of things part of
it is the the program the economic
program of hyperglobalism I mean I think
that these these companies let's take
just the social media companies in the
United States for example companies like
Facebook or now I guess they want us to
call them meta I think is an absurd name
but you know they they feel the need
they're they're truly they're based in
the United States but they're
multinational corporations they say that
they've got to become absolutely
gargantuan and huge in order to compete
on a global scale so the globalization
helps Drive massive scale I mean just
gigantic so they get to be huge they get
to be multinational in size and then
many of these companies United States
have had special deals with the United
States government and when it comes to
the social media companies the social
media companies benefit from special
exemptions in under American law that no
other company does and so we treat them
differently they've been given special
exemptions that are worth billions to
them Jordan a year since the 1990s so
this combination of of government
favoritism
along with globalization I think has led
to increasing monopolization and that's
not been good for anybody it's been bad
for competition it's been bad for
Innovation it's been bad for Americans
as consumers but maybe worst of all it's
been bad for them as producers
so
so that's an interesting platform for
conservatives and revolutionary in some
sense to concentrate on the local again
to concentrate on the working class to
be concerned about the development of
fascistic monopolies at the higher end
but it it's a it's an interesting uh
when I talked to pauliev or watch
poliov's campaigning in Canada
it's so interesting watching his rallies
because they look to me like working
class rallies that were characteristic
of the labor movement in the 1970s it's
the same people attending and I think it
is this concentration on the local that
is driving that rather than
concentration on big business let's say
and so that is an opportunity for
conservatives in the U.S to capture that
massive base of 70 percent you said who
are fundamentally working class in
orientation by actually serving their
needs properly and since the entire
infrastructure of Western culture
depends in some ways on the Integrity of
the working class in some fundamental
manner then that seems to be good policy
all around
that I think you've I think what you
just said is is absolutely critical
which is that
in the United States
the the kind of the the culture that
we've been talking about the culture of
work the culture of family the culture
of faith that has been and still is a
fundamentally middle class working class
culture
and so what you've seen is is that as
the middle class and working class in
this country has become economically
weaker
in these last few decades as they have
become culturally weaker they've also
become in some sense politically weaker
and the left has capitalized on that and
I think part of what what Republicans
and conservatives need to be saying is
we want to make all Americans but
especially working Americans stronger we
want to make their voices stronger we
want to make their life prospects
stronger we want to make their
institutions stronger their family
stronger their neighborhoods stronger we
need to be a party in a movement that
says we are for the strength of the
working people of this country we're
forced because this is this they're the
foundation of this country and we are
for strengthening the fundamentals of
America I think that's that is a hopeful
forward-looking
affirmative agenda that can be built out
and should be built out in a number of
different ways and that that's my view
what are your hopes for the Republican
party as we move out of 2022 in the
midterms towards the 2024 presidential
election if you had a best case scenario
for what the Republican Party does in
the next two years what would that look
like
well I hope that what we'll do is in
Congress at least which is where I'll be
serving I hope that we will be putting
forward an alternative agenda that will
be along the lines that we've just
discussed I hope that we'll come forward
and we'll say we want to give you more
control over your kids education you
ought to be able for instance to know
what your kids are being taught you
ought to be able to have a say in that
you ought to be able to have control
over your kids curriculum we want to
give you more control and more
opportunity economically we want to
bring back good paying jobs to this
country we want to strengthen the family
we want to reward you for having kids
not punish you for having kids I propose
a Jordan legislation that would give
parents working parents a massive tax
cut if they stay together and have kids
and I think what we ought to be saying
is it's not just that we shouldn't be
penalizing you for being married we
ought to be rewarding you if you get
married and having a family you are
contributing to society you ought to get
the benefit of that we should be
explicitly rewarding that and
strengthening families strengthening
marriage strengthening getting kids so I
hope that we'll put forward an agenda
that's focused on that
as an alternative Joe Biden of course is
going to be president for the next two
years we need to not just be stopping
what he's doing although my view that's
very important but we need to be putting
forward an alternative that
fundamentally contrasts with the
campaign of nihilism that he on the left
are are attempting to Foster so I hope
that's what we'll do and I think if we
do that we'll go into 2024 and we'll be
able to offer the country
two fundamentally different visions
what do you think is going to happen on
the leadership front
I don't know the answer to that listen
if I had to predict I would say Donald
Trump is giving every indication that he
will run again and I think that he'll be
the nominee I mean I I just I haven't I
haven't asked him directly if he's going
to run but I think he is Jordan I mean
he's he's said it publicly I'd be very
surprised at this point if he didn't so
I think that he will be the nominee and
uh I hope that if he is the nominee that
he will put forward an agenda that will
be focused on the best of what he did as
president and I think the best of what
he did as president was he focused on
bringing back American jobs he focused
on trying to strengthen the economic
conditions of of the working class in
the middle class and he tried to defend
American culture those are good things I
hope that he will he will put forward a
positive agenda that will do that and
will seek to move the country forward to
a position of strength and uh you know
we'll see I mean we'll see who do you
see as potential contenders against
Trump in the primaries do you think
DeSantis will throw his hat in the ring
you know I don't know the answer to that
I I sort of doubt it I mean my feeling
is is that if Trump wants to be the
nominee he will be the nominee and I
think that that I think that most folks
probably think that so I would be listen
I don't I don't know Governor DeSantis
personally so I couldn't I couldn't
speculate I'd be a little surprised if
if any
um serious presidential Contender
decided to run if Trump ran because I
think it would it would be almost
certain defeat but who knows I could be
wrong and two years is a long time in
the primaries won't kick off for over a
year a year and a half I mean that's an
eternity in in politics so who knows and
what do you think the the immediate
Necessities let's say are that are going
to confront
um a republican Congress and a
Republican Senate assuming that that's
the way things turn out in the midterms
what would you like to see happen on the
on the political front and then in the
short to medium term
well I think one of the things we have
to look at immediately is is energy in
the United States during the rampant
inflation that is you you talk about
just cutting the guts out of of the
working people and their families this
rampant inflation that this government
has given us is doing that and energy
costs are a huge part of that Joe Biden
when he came to office on one of the
first things he did during the series of
executive orders he signed you talk
about power the president has a lot of
it he shut down new oil and energy
production in this country he canceled
existing leases he stopped the the
future uh issuance of of leases on
federal lands which is a huge part of
our oil production we need to reverse
all of those policies I mean we need to
be a pro-energy production in this
country to me to see the president go
from from country to Country and getting
down and begging these dictators yes
yeah to increase oil production because
we won't produce it in the United States
of America is insane it is the
definition of insanity flirting with
Iran flirting with Venezuela going cap
and him to the Saudis will also beg
moral tricks on them yeah yeah that was
really quite spectacular canceling the
Keystone Pipeline system exactly of
course graded on Canadian sensibility
except perhaps well I would say even on
the sensibility of our prime minister
interestingly enough
so yeah well it's also the case we might
point out too that
um America is one of the only countries
that has managed to cut carbon dioxide
output and that was mostly a consequence
of fracking which isn't something that
the environmentalists would have ever
first of all predicted or certainly not
trumpeted once it happened and so it's
certainly possible that a U.S that's
dynamic in relationship to its energy
production could be a net force for good
even on the environmental front so I
think that's almost certain and as well
as on the economic front particularly in
relationship to the finances of the
poorest people because they're so
dependent on energy
that's right and I just don't know two
things about that the first thing is I
don't know why you would want countries
like dictatorships like Saudi Arabia and
Venezuela and others to be getting the
to be reaping the benefit of the the
billions and probably eventually
trillions of dollars of energy
production that we are foregoing and
have it benefiting their their
dictatorships I also don't know why
you'd want countries that to your point
don't have the same environmental
standards have lower environment
environmental standards than the United
States have why should they be the ones
who are producing all the world's energy
but finally why shouldn't American
workers this is this this energy agenda
Biden's climate agenda is a deeply
anti-worker agenda they are telling the
the men who work the rigs uh the the men
who work the pipelines they put them out
of work the men who go down into the
coal mines put them out of work in favor
of buying oil from Saudi Arabia and
Venezuela and Iran it is it is just
crazy and so I think that a fundamental
in the short term a fundamental
Cornerstone of a pro-worker agenda
frankly pro-america agenda is we have
got to turn on American energy
production and put American workers back
to work the other thing Jordan we have
to do is crime in this country
is just at stratospheric levels and it
is a you talk about the basic fabric of
society if a parent if a mom can't send
her kids out to go you know get a gallon
of milk at the local gas station if they
can't go wait for the bus on the corner
and not be afraid they're going to get
shot at you have a problem and that's
increasingly where we are in many cities
today in America we have got to restore
some basic respect for the rule of law
and that's not hard listen I'm a former
prosecutor that means you prosecute
criminals you put them behind bars and
you reward those who follow the law
and we've got to start doing that and
why isn't Joe Biden doing it it's
because once again they think that the
criminal justice system is systemically
racist and therefore we shouldn't
prosecute criminals if there's something
wrong with that well there isn't
something wrong with that there's
something good about punishing those who
do wrong rewarding those who do right
and I think a basic thing Republicans
have got to do is we have got to say
we're going to get serious about crime
and restore some basic safety to
families in this country
well that seems like a salutary point to
end our discussion is there anything
else that you wanted to bring to the
attention of people who are watching and
listening when is your book coming out
by the way it'll be out next spring
it'll be out in the spring of of 2023
and uh I'm I'm really excited about it
it's just been a great privilege for me
to get to work on this on this topic and
to get to to talk to so many men and
young men and I look forward to getting
to do that more and more well good maybe
we can have another podcast when your
book comes out I look forward to that
I'd look forward to that yeah it'd be
good to talk maybe jointly with someone
like Warren Farrell and and and uh dive
deep into that particular set of issues
so well thank you very much for talking
with me today I I hope we continue to
stay in touch I'll I'll be in touch with
you and some of the other issues that we
discussed and
um appreciate very much your candor and
your willingness to talk to me today and
uh everyone who's watching and listening
and your attention is always appreciated
and uh I hope you found today's
discussion useful and maybe even
optimistic and hopeful at least on the
American front that'd be lovely to see
the U.S Thrive mightily over the next
few years especially on the energy front
in a world that's increasingly in Dire
Straits because of utterly foolish and
Preposterous energy policies and so
you may have done a bad job in the
United States but you haven't done as
terrible a job as most countries have so
that's something
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com